we're going to be doing a 100 000
challenge inside of far cry 6. it's
going to be a 2v2 challenge me and chris
versus carl and chandler the first
person to defeat the five random
outposts i pick wins 100 000
i could pay for my wedding is everyone
standing at the end of the piers yes all
right don't leave the end of the piers
the challenge has not started
don't leave what go carl come on we have
to win 100 grand mark it on the map for
us all right we're going to start with
this one down here oh you know what then
we're going to the top we're in the air
baby thank you ubisoft for sponsoring
the video chris can you drive any slower
it's a helicopter bro it only has one
speed
chris stop shooting it and go let's get
out here
oh are we getting shot chris
oh
did you jump out yeah i was parachuting
and you didn't tell me i'm all the way
back on the island oh no
we're 2 000 meters away is that far
incoming missile get out
i died i died you died come on carl
let's do this far we have to win where
are the people are they inside
[Music]
got one down
oh i killed a civilian we're good come
on let's get you a kill gator kill up
where are they
oh i have a flame shotgun we're back
attempt number two we gotta go fast we
gotta make up for lost time we're going
gun to blazin
all right two down these guys ain't
nothing private herandez how about you
kiss my privates oh you're driving away
sorry you're dead now oh they're coming
they're coming in blazing this guy
thought he was gonna drive in here
i hear some oh there it is i think we're
going for speed here
oh you think you're good
boom oh that didn't kill him
we did it we did the first one holy cow
there we go shut the pilot out boom
we've captured one outpost four more to
go
starting to feel a little op are we i've
seen what you can do mr beast gaming
i admit you're skilled but don't confuse
luck with talent
let's see what you can do
all right we gotta hurry up let's go all
right get in and then set away point
dang 2 000 meters to the next one all
right get in the car all right go go go
go go your robo dog's coming no we don't
need my robo dog if you did win what
would you spend the 50 000 on put some
money on to my house paying a mortgage
is scary look at him being financially
responsible
everything is hitting us right now
i'm on fire don't worry jimmy i got a
tractor yeah we need a helicopter this
is dumb let's go
we gotta find him
right here
he's dead troops inbound from the north
oh they're right there oh okay i'm
coming
hi nice vehicle
you're dead coming in on our second one
we finally got a helicopter here i'm
gonna call chandler
jimmy's calling me on my phone ignore
him chandler how many outposts have you
guys beat three you beat three i don't
believe you buy chris he said he beat
three i do believe him we're screwed go
we don't have time to wait
you did
you did i cut 20 bullets left give me
ammo
give me ammo i got five bullets left go
inside make sure there's nobody inside
still where are you quit hiding well i
think i found him all right go go go go
go go go go go
hey bud
all right we did it we did it we're
gonna win we got three more outpost
number two down three more to go and
while we're making our journey to this
next outpost i want to tell you a little
bit more about far cry 6. as you can
obviously see far cry 6 has the ability
to play with a friend it's always more
fun together
there are also new resolver weapons like
a flamethrower a backpack that shoots
rockets and a freaking cd launcher a cd
launcher cd these nuts this game is just
genuinely fun and features cinematic
action the best far cry villain to date
and an incredible story it's like a
movie so if you're interested in playing
far cry 6 click the link description to
play it on pc playstation 4 playstation
5 and the brand new xbox xor s so click
the link in description to buy far cry 6
right now so you can play it on october
7th when it comes out santo gusto coffee
factory here we come we have to do this
one quick though all right i'm hopping
out okay i'm gonna try to just fight
from here
oh never mind i'm super not shooting
from a helicopter and we still have a
helicopter yep
i'll post number two down three more to
go all right go go go go go go go is
there ammo here there's gotta be ammo
here somewhere right he is a bad guy and
i don't have any ammo
why does he have so much else i'm on
fire i'm on fire this is such a hard
outpost oh my gosh wait i have a
firework launcher what does this do
ah stop shooting fireworks at me i'm on
your team i'm just shooting fireworks i
don't know what to tell you they're
literally coming right towards me jimmy
hit the jeeps
oh no one more guy all right we got one
more truck coming in
oh wow we did it number three number
three let's go baby we gotta catch up
there's no helicopter pad here instead
of going around like the map suggests
we're gonna cut through and make our own
path all right it's not that far of a
swim we're going we're heading to gran
roca telecom station dude if we don't
get a helicopter at this one we might
lose i'm just throwing that out there
hello
baby get in get in
we're still marked on the map here we go
baby carl chandler we moved you in how
are you guys doing oh terrible we've
done two really we're on number two as
well like actually and by number two i
mean we're swimming across a freaking
river to get to number four
carl chandler before we move you out
don't forget that a hundred thousand
dollars is on the line oh we know baby
oh we're not forgetting we'll do the
same thing as last time it worked really
well
oh my god okay okay i didn't know i'm
getting out they're shooting heavy
i'm getting murdered out here this one's
hard all right let's go hey chris are
you ready i'm a doma guy
i miss it's kind of quiet
too quiet i see you guys up here i'm
going
got him oh you're gone there's a guy
right in front of you i have no ammo i
have no ammo that's it i'm using my
special gun
[Applause]
[Music]
holy cow this thing's op
guapo is down
i'm revive club
how dare they
nobody does that and gets away with it
oh i think i have poison gas can spray
your poison spray killed him helicopter
oh my god there's another helicopter
oh i got him head shot baby
oh my god
whoa holy cow we have one left we're one
more capture away from a hundred grand
carl oh my gosh why is it taking so long
chris we're gonna lose money get in cue
the intense music
hey check these out check these out
ah
i died what just happened oh oh my god
there's so many people in here he's
right here i found him
oh my god why are you running
that was outpost number four we only
have one left get back in here chandler
all right let's go we need to go back
all right last one carl we can do this
i'm definitely not on fire right now i'm
definitely not on fire
oh help all right we gotta get a
helicopter and get out of here all right
mark it on the map mark it on the map
for us where is there a helicopter oh
there it is oh there's people in here
there's people in the ship die die die
i think the helicopter's the last thing
i'm just shooting it screw it
yeah
100 baby let's go gg baby chandler carl
what number outpost are you on oh
we finished five chris can you come here
you you lost money then congratulations
on winning fifty thousand dollars a year
and thank you ubisoft for sponsoring
this video we appreciate you